اليوم نحن موجودين بسلطنه عمان هذا البلد
الجميل جدا والذي يتمتع بطبيعه خليبه
لتجربه احدى السيارات فور الفورد افرست
هذا المد سايز اس يو
[موسيقى]
في على الونز بدنا نشوف هذا الافرست شو
قدر يعمل
يلاس جو جايز انا المومنتم
نطلع عندي حوالي 300 حصان عندي 420 نيوتن
متر
واو واو واو
[موسيقى]
واوب الافرست بالهي
مالايا هار ولكن
هذا سياره رائعه
رائعه
كيف تختبروا السياره بتختبر بهالطريقه
تاخذوها على الصحراء بتشوفوا
اذا
فورست
[موسيقى]
صدقوني تقولوا لي ما في سياره اقو مننا
واحسن مننا بالطبع ولكن هذه السياره
بالسعر الذي ستقدم به ي راح تحصلوا عليه
انا عمق ايديشن
هلا
بالتجهيزات بصمت مكسوره القياده وبنظام
الدفع الرباعي يلي قدرت اتخطى فييه
الكسبين
[موسيقى]
الرمليه سياره لكل يوم للمغامرات للعائله
للاولاد لللز ولكن ايضا لهذه المغامره
اللي بتعملوها مره يمكن بحياتكم وتنبسطوا
فيها كثير وما
[موسيقى]
واو عاده وقت بكون عم بجرب سياره بحب اعمل
كونكلوشن من خارج السياره ولكن ما الي قلب
انزل من الفورد افرست ليه ما تتمتع به هذه
السياره من صفات بدي اقوللكم شغله ان كان
نظام التعليق او قدره المحرك يلي هو من
اربع اطون او العزم التور 420 نيوتن مترز
وحتى السعر بجعله من هذه السياره سليح
كثير قوي ايدرا فورد نافس فيه على صعيد
السيرات الميت سايز السوديه بالشرق الاوسط
واربح
المعركه
ه